AOC is breaking up with Democrat Senator
Bob Menendez and calling on him to
resign
should he resign and what do you think
of his statement that it has to do with
him being a Latino well you know I think
it's the situation is uh quite
unfortunate but I do believe that it is
in the best interests for Senator
Menendez to resign in this moment as you
mentioned consistency matters it
shouldn't matter whether it's a
Republican or a Democrat the details in
this indictment are extremely serious
they involve the nature of
of not just his but all of our seats in
Congress and while you know as a Latina
there are absolutely ways in which there
is systemic bias but I think what is
here in this indictment is quite clear
and um and I believe it is in the best
interest to maintain the Integrity of
the seat
it's a pretty good answer why is AOC
turning on her man her compatriot here
well because they got him dead to rights
everyone knows that Menendez is corrupt
we've known it for a decade now at least
and because New Jersey is safe so
they'll just appoint some other Democrat
there who's probably going to be better
who's probably going to be closer to the
AOC line of thinking Bob Menendez is not
the most far left radical in the Senate
and who's probably going to be younger
is going to be there for longer so it's
a simple calculation if you're AOC
in politics you got to know when to hold
them know when to hold them no one to
walk away no one to run and Bob Menendez
is just totally toxic here's menendez's
excuse
the Feds catch him with 480 thousand
dollars in cash stashed around his house
and stuffed into the pockets of his
clothing in envelopes they didn't even
take it out of the envelopes from the
bribes they find bars of gold I mean
they find bribes
and his excuse is this
for 30 years I have withdrawn thousands
of dollars in cash from my personal
savings account which I've kept for
emergencies and because of the history
of my family facing confiscation in Cuba
now this may seem old-fashioned but
these were monies drawn from my personal
savings account based on the income that
I have lawfully derived over those 30
years I look forward to addressing other
issues at trial
you know it's it's probably the best he
could have come up with
but this is so preposterous
is saying look he's saying the same
excuse that he said right away right
away when they caught him he said look
they're just coming after me because I'm
Latino I didn't even know Bob Menendez
was Latino I know he has a Hispanic last
name but you look at him he just looks
like an ordinary white guy
he looks like every mildly Italian man
that I know from the tri-state area
but he's a slightly different kind of
swarthy so he gets to say that he's
Latino and they're coming after me
because I'm Latino they waited a long
time to do it but now they're coming
after me because I'm Latino they don't
understand the only reason I had a half
a million dollars in cash stash around
my house is because I'm Latino and I
remember the dark days of Castro and
that's why I need to keep half a million
in cash around my house it was all
lawfully withdrawn from my lawful
earnings from my bank account
did he also withdraw the bars of gold
from his bank account did he did he push
I didn't know because I know you go to
the ATM and you collected you want 20s
do you want 50s do you want bars of gold
I don't that's great that's cool I'm
glad maybe I'll try that in the future
they're kind of expensive though aren't
they can you withdraw Mercedes from your
bank bank account
no I was just withdrawing it from my my
earnings how about home furnishings
how about mortgage payments can you
withdraw you could withdraw those from
your bank account but that would come
from your bank account not someone
else's when the investigators went
around this guy's house they found on
the envelopes of the bribes they found
the Fingerprints of the Crooked
businessman who bribed him
they have got this guy completely dead
to rights and the proof that they got
him dead to rights
is Menendez just hired a lawyer to
defend him
and the lawyer he hired is the same
lawyer that Hunter Biden hired
there you go just book him at this point
this is according to CNBC Menendez has
hired Abby Lowell
to represent him in this case he already
hired that lawyer in 2015. I guess Abby
Lowell is just the Democrat lawyer who
represents crooked Dems that's it that
if you are a high-ranking crooked
Democrat who they've got dead to rights
you hire this
guy
and yet according to experts the
evidence in this case is much much
stronger than was in the 15K case so
Democrats are going to flee probably
he'll have to resign right now text
Knowles to 98 98 98 Vladimir Putin
called the US Dollars drop in dominance
objective and irreversible as Brazil
Russia India China and South Africa
formally agreed to use local currencies
in trade instead of the US dollar as
demand for the dollar weakens the buying
power of the dollar weekends that is why
Birch gold is busier than ever investors
and Savers are looking to harness the
power of physical gold held in a tax
sheltered Ira you can too you can
protect your IRA or 401K by diversifying
with gold from Birch gold as the US
dollar continues to receive pressure
from foreign countries digital currency
and central banks arm yourself with
information on how to protect your
savings learn if gold is right for you
too text Knowles Canada WLS to 98 98 98
they will send you a free info kit on
gold with an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers and countless five-star
reviews I trust Birch gold to help you
diversify into gold if Central Bank
digital currency becomes a reality it
will be nice to have some gold to depend
upon again right now text Knowles Canada
98.98 98 David McCormick running for
Senate he's a former hedge funder he
could be a self-fundor he's a very
competent guy he's obviously a very
intelligent guy
I felt he was a better candidate than Dr
Oz in uh the last cycle in Pennsylvania
uh he wants to take over the seat
uh as Bob Casey Democrat in Pennsylvania
becomes more vulnerable as a result of
how terrible a job Biden has done
he's a fine candidate but he's socially
pretty liberal
on on the social issues
things like
marriage rock ribbidness on issues of
Life uh
McCormick is not the most hardcore
right-wing guy in the world now the
argument for someone like a McCormick or
even for Dr Oz is well look it's
Pennsylvania
you're not going to run a far right-wing
candidate you're not going to run a rock
ribbed conservative and win there
so
just take the squish
and be happy that you get anyone with an
R next to his name
I just don't think that's necessarily
true it wasn't so long ago that Rick
Santorum was Senator from Pennsylvania
Rick Santorum one of the most Rock
ribbed
traditional socially conservative
right-wing candidates that we've had in
recent history and by the way the guy
almost got himself the nomination for
president
don't forget when he was running against
Mitt Romney
Pennsylvania liked Rick Santorum
eventually he lost but he served some
time in Pennsylvania
why can't we nominate a Santorum
you want to talk about Mitt Romney Mitt
Romney lost Pennsylvania Donald Trump
won Pennsylvania Donald Trump a much
more right-wing figure than Mitt Romney
are we really so convinced that to win
Pennsylvania you need to have some Meek
and Mild
totally acceptable
to the
liberal mainstream kind of candidate I'm
not convinced of that at all it's the
Rust Belt baby
in some ways a hedge funder is anathema
to the way that pennsylvanians view
their politics
I don't really want to dis McCormick I
think in many ways he's a good candidate
and I I would have supported him over in
Oz last time
but are there other candidates could we
get a Santorum like figure could we get
could we get a trump-like figure a
trump-like figure who is suited to
Pennsylvania
Romney lost McCain lost I don't know
where's where's the Santorum figure
we just get Santorum to run again that'd
be great I would love that boy what a
great clip that was now
make sure that you ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael Knowles podcast
we'll see you next time